hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday November 6
2023 what's going on how are
you how the [__] are you oh my God I'm
wiped out man I'm [__] my voice is
tired I did two shows at
Foxwoods yesterday and it is the woods
it's the middle of [__]
nowhere um not really the middle of
nowhere I always thought it was further
out into the woods but it's definitely a
drive off the highway I always wondered
why the hell they put it way out there
maybe it's a reservation I have no
idea but um had a great time I want to
thank everybody that came out to the
shows um yet another corporate stupid
[__] thing trying to Penny pinch and
make more money right we [__] drive
there from
Boston and
uh I get there like 2 3 in the afternoon
no menu in the [__] room nothing on
the TV no
nothing all right all freckles is hungry
hey want some
grub so I call up the
[__] they push the button from room
service the lady's like hey thank you
for
fo she immediately goes just to let you
know we have a limited
menu right like it's one in the morning
I'm like what do you mean you have a
limited we have a limited menu until
like 5:00 and she's like you can get
like a ham and cheese
[__] hand roll roll up thing or a
turkey one or like a cheese
pizza and I literally just go like how
much how much money did and she's like
it's not me I go I know it's not you I
go to the you got they got you making
the food yet to answering the phones
they making the food and she laughs and
she goes not
yet it's [__] unbeliev like it's
just when when is somebody going to step
in with these corporations and just be
like okay you guys you've taken it too
far you've
exhausted the ways that you can just
[__] people over now you're like barely
even doing your
job well what if we uh don't have the
cook come in until
uh after 5:00 and uh during the day
we'll just feed people like they're at a
[__]
airport anyway I ended up going down to
that Junior's Cheesecake
thing [__]
[__] so [__] sick of that I
didn't want to get into it I'm you know
I'm going to stay in a good mood okay I
got a nice little I have a day off on
the road here I'm on my final [__] we
have a limited menu 3 in the [__]
afternoon
I'm trying to think what the [__]
angle is you know they're going to blame
Co and the Taliban or some you know
whatever's going on in [__] Israel
they always come up with some sort of
[__] excuse and it's all [__] it
has to do with the fact that if they do
it that way if there's a limited day we
can have the the the [__] the cook at
night make all the [__] sandwiches he
can [__] off and we can keep selling
food with nobody down
there and we'll just just have one
person answer the phone by the way there
was like [__] 50 Rings before anybody
even picked
up hi welcome to Foxwoods just to let
you know we're not really going to
[__] you know do our jobs until
[__]
5:00 tell you what's funny is they do
all of these goddamn things about the
mafia and and and all of the [__] that
they did and and every [__] old
dealer I I've ever met in a casino said
it was way better way better when the
mob ran it they were way less greedy I'm
not saying that they were good
people all right I'm not saying that I'm
just saying you know even they had a
[__]
line you know what it was was that they
what they were doing was
illegal most of their you
know I guess in Vegas you know the
gambling was legal but what what most of
their scams were all [__] illegal
so they kind of had you know they had to
watch
it but now the corporations basically
are on the legal legal side of stealing
and they took all of their sh they took
all of their scams and now they can just
go as far as they [__] want because
nobody in politics has any backbone no
one's looking out for [__]
people it's like isn't it enough you
turn the [__] food supply into poison
like what I'm eating is going to be full
of some sort of [__] hormones that's
going to give me a disease at the end of
my [__] life isn't that enough can't
you have somebody [__] there to
prepare it Oh Billy grumpy oh grumpy
bill
um anyway you know what's funny is how
uh people look at people in cars and
they just sort of sum them up what kind
of car you have is who the [__] you are
you know it's just on Instagram cuz I'm
addicted to my goddamn phone
um and this guy caught this woman using
his
charger for uh for her Tesla or some
[__] like that right which I didn't know
they had Teslas over in England I don't
really remember but that was the comment
in the thing and the guy was I guess was
at work and was looking at his [__]
security he must have had England Simply
Safe and he's like right right what what
you doing she's like right I'm I'm using
I'm using the charger I'm charging me
car me car needs a me car needs a charge
he's like right but it's me
charger she's like yeah but you're not
using it he's like right but it's me
charger and she just kept coming up with
his I'm seeing me friend across the
street right what's her name L uh Lucy
seeing Lucy I'm using you know me car
needs a
charger and she couldn't get it through
her [__] thick head that what she was
doing was [__]
up so of course in the comments somebody
writes typical
entitlement of a Tesla
driver and I'm laughing going like have
you ever even [__] talked to a a
Tesla driver there's like people they
just
[__] I remember when I drove the
Prius like the amount of [__]
stereotypes that came with driving a
[__]
Prius um but I do it
too this guy [__] annoyed me last
week and I was talking to a friend of
mine I was like I did [__] G wagon
ice bath [__] [__] you know and I
didn't even see his car I just assumed
with his [__] attitude he drove a G
wagon you know those jerk offs that
drive G
wagons the stupidest [__] car in the
road that big dumb toaster driving down
the street and they all think it's like
a badass vehicle that is a goofy looking
[__] truck on the goddamn
Road whenever I look at it it just looks
like looks like like three books you
know standing up on a
bookshelf just a big
[__] it looks like a kid drew it you
know nobody's like loud and like driving
fast and I just I always I always put
those people like in you know like these
these [__] idiots that for some
reason think they need to to take an ice
bath after their very like mediocre
workout down at the gym you know and you
can't just like take a [__] ice bath
right you got to make a video and you
got to put it on social media and the
whole thing is about when you get into
the ice bath you don't make a
noise right and they all act like
they're trying to help you going like
you know hey it's the end of my workout
you know going to take a little ice bath
here well just [__] take the ice
bath the [__] are you talking to me
about it for right you know this is good
for like
inflammation it's like what did you do
at the
gym that you got to treat your body like
a bag of frozen [__]
broccoli I'm not going to lie to you I
was one of those dumb asses I did I did
some ice baths I didn't feel anything I
didn't feel any benefits or any of that
[__] all I knew is you just got in it
and it sucked for [__] 40 seconds and
then you just sat there and your body
acclimated it was kind of no big deal
the more you did it the less it bothered
you I probably did like seven or eight
of those
things before I realized that it was
[__]
stupid like there's no [__] way I
need to be doing this with how the the
amount of time that I'm working
out I've gone this far in life without
doing a nice I'll take a [__] cold
shower just sitting here it's really
this is really great it boosts your
immune system and D then all of these
[__] [__] saying this [__] how
many even like researched it they're
just saying what the [__] other people
saying because at the end of the day an
ice bath okay is that's the guy version
of like these [__] workout [__]
that try to act like they're showing you
how to get abs and what they're really
doing is just showing off their
bodies you know what I mean it's like oh
I'm working out it's like oh yeah were
you going to put on any workout
clothes why are you in your underwear
with your [__] clam peeking
out you know do sweatpants really get
that much in your way when you do
squats right this is good for you bum
um a bunch of self- involved [__]
[__] you know why can't everybody be
like me you
know what the [__] am I doing here now I
just turned on the
flashlight the whole thing's falling
apart here there we go shutting it off
um I don't know yeah so my my thing is
that if you drive a G wagon I think
uh there's
like
there's like an 80%
chance you take an ice bath all right oh
this is good this is like this is let's
let's do car
stereotypes you like write
in
um I don't know whatever you think of
each person there's a comedian man he
did a hilarious bit on people that drive
Ford
F-150s and whenever they park it they
they pull the mirrors into the side of
the truck rather than looking into them
and figuring out what's wrong with them
as a
[Music]
person and I could laugh at it cuz I
drive an
F250 which means I'm 100 points better
than someone that drives a 150 and every
once in a while I drive my 250 down the
street and somebody pulls up next to me
in an F350 and that always bugs me cuz I
know that they're 100 points better than
me I don't mind an F450 or an F550 I
don't mind those because those people
are going to work all right but when I
see an F350 pull up with nothing in the
bed just like me I know that he's 100
points better than me and that I lost
you know and if my wife is there I try
to distract her so she won't look over
at that other man that I know is better
than
me um anyway I had a
uh I had an
incredible [__] night in uh Boston
Massachusetts
um first of all I went to that
[__] what the hell is it called Tate
or I don't even know what it's called in
Boston I looked up the word it's the
Hebrew word for
grandmother so I'm like all right that's
now now I'm starting to get it cuz who
cooks better than your grandmother huh
maybe your mom if your grandmother sucks
at cooking but just in general you know
if you have a grandmother that's still
[__] cooking for people right she
understands life so I'm like all right
this is great you know I'm getting the
Jewish
version of their grandmother's cooking
and everything but I don't even get the
food when I go there I went to CH Street
and I went to this place it's the best
[__] espresso in the
country it's the most ridiculously
flavorful it is the the uh you know you
know Starbucks espresso is the [__]
Antichrist like I don't even know what
they doing they just burn the [__] out
of the beans and just throw it in one of
their stupid cups and they have the
nerve to charge you for it right just
you know the balance of the Universe I
got to get the name of it um I'll
figured I'll post it later whatever
there's two locations in Boston there
was one over near where the new Emerson
College is just as delicious I like the
one on Charles Street better I just like
like that street
so I get that
coffee it's [__] delicious right
first of all I'm standing in line and I
said to the pastry lady goes can I help
you I said yeah can I get a double
espresso and she just looks at me and
she goes you order up at the register
pastries here only and I just started
[__] laughing going I know by the way
she just said that there must have been
at least three signs telling me that
before I said that [__] to her and I
went back the next day and she wasn't
there cuz if was there I was going to
order coffee again just to see what
she'd
[Laughter]
do so anyways it was [__]
delicious and I walked up Beacon Hill I
think that's what it's called there cuz
I wanted to look at Lewisburg
Square because I'm always reading my
kids Make Way for
Ducklings you know and there's a you
know there's a lot of like you know it's
the Swan Boats Lewisburg Square which I
never even heard of of it's this own
little it's almost like gramar SE Park
in New York City where it's like that's
this is our Park our Brown Brownstones
like fa it cuz you went up there you're
not allowed to go in the park the park
is
private and there's a gate that goes
around the whole thing there's only one
entrance that I saw and it was locked
and there was a little
sign with a little doggy bag on it that
said this this is [__] private this
is our Park okay you're common you go to
the Boston Commons you go down there you
deal with people with mental problems
that we no longer try to help
out all right that's where you belong so
I was a little disappointed that you
couldn't go into the [__] Park so I
took some video for my kids and then I
went along the Charles River and I tried
to find that little island you know next
to
uh what is it massav Bridge or something
like that where the [__] mother is
and the the the feathers start to Mt and
all of that [__] I was just having a
great time
right so uh in the afternoon I had to do
soundcheck because I was doing Comics
come home and I was playing double drums
basically with Charlie um Dennis L's
drummer on The [__] Song and Mark
Maron was playing guitar and Mark can
[__] play like he can really really
really I don't people I don't think
people understand
how [__] good a guitarist that guy is
he was on con one time he's just ripping
with the band man he's [__] fantastic
I'm you know I'm a Guitar Center dad I
can go there I can play When the Levy
Breaks and uh just don't ask me to
[__] do anything beyond that right so
I went down there you know we were all
just [__] around we ended up playing
like Zeppelin the ocean we played a
little walk this way just [__] around
and then figuring out like what we were
going to
do
um went back I don't know I got
something to eat and then we came down
and did the show I had to go on
last um it's funny cuz people like oh
you're closing it it's like no you on
those shows you go on last I remember
talking to Patrice about that a long
time like on a show like that where
everybody's doing 15 you're not closing
it out you're going on
last you're not headlining you go on
last there's no meat left on the bone
and uh everybody [__] murdered and
before the thing even
started they brought a bunch of the brw
you know cam NE has always does this
Great heartfelt speech and then they
brought up all of these Bruins I'm going
to try to remember each era so from the
2011 Stanley Cup era they had uh in like
the last 10 years they had Milan
Lich they had Patrice berson and tuar
rasque and then they had um from my era
they had Ray Bor Ken
lindman the original rap on the Bruins
Ken lindman and Raymond
bour and then they had from pre Bobby or
through Bobby yor there John the chief
buk down there I couldn't [__]
believe it
um got to meet all of them Shake all
their
hands uh it was just insane and then the
show started and I mean everybody
[__] ripped Tammy Pas Tammy
pascatelli uh Rachel Feinstein I'm
trying to remember everybody's [__]
name on the thing Lenny Clark Pete
Davidson everybody Bobby Kelly Mark
Maron um this kid Orlando Boston guy I
forget his last name um everybody just
had a [__] great time and like the
next
day you know I ended up smoking I smoked
a cigar with Jay Miller my favorite
[__]
Bruin you know during the Cam Neely era
in the 80s and I'm smoking a cigar I'm
[__] sitting there what Jay Miller
and he's telling me about all of his
fights and [__] is [__] insane and uh
the next day like I'm sitting there
drinking another delicious coffee
right
um I was just thinking about how awesome
my life is was just like how the [__]
did all of that happen you know so thank
you to Cam Neely and Dennis liry for
giving me yet another [__] make a
wish day in my
life um it's always an honor to come
back thank you to everybody that came
out to the show it was
fantastic um yeah and then I went down
to uh went down to Foxwoods last night
had a great time two shows and that one
I had a bunch of people I used to
work a long time ago I'm going to take
you through my whole [__] life here I
used to work at this place called
corporate
software um way back in the day way way
way the [__] back in the day I'm talking
1986 to like
1989 I worked in this place that was
sort of like an Amazon before Amazon
where instead of having to go to 5,000
different stores you just go to One
location and they did computer software
we were like a we we just ordered
software in bulk from all these
different companies had it in the
warehouse and then people would just
call us rather than to have the ra and
just put in all their orders for
software rather than having to call all
these other ones right it was ahead of
its time the company totally blew up and
the the people that bought it ended up
going public and they sold it and they
made a ton of [__]
money um that's not what I did I
unloaded the
trucks loaded and unloaded trucks so my
old
boss from back in the day uh he came
there and then two of my he came out to
the show and two uh with his wife and
two of uh my former Co co-workers came
down and we were just [__] talking
about the old days it's funny they all
drive trucks and one of my buddies
switched from Ford to Silverado and I
just can't believe it's like how the
[__] could you do that it's like be
going from like the Red Sox to the
Yankees or the other way back that's
another thing that I don't [__]
understand like
um like the the level that Ford and
Chevy truck drivers [__] battle with
each other and [__] on it and then like
what's funny is nobody gives a [__]
about Dodge
trucks you know like they're never like
brought in they just sort of like I
don't know what they are they're like
that team that never wins
it never wins the championship like the
Royals back in the day before they
finally got another one you know and
then nobody gives a [__] about a Toyota
Tundra or those full-size trucks that
the uh that Japanese people uh make you
know what what's the Nissan one I have
no [__] idea but like Ford and
[__] Chevy I don't know what happened
back in the day but the I remember the
commercials like they'd show a Ford
truck driving up a hill going over all
these speed bumps and it would be
carrying like a a [__] Chevy square
body they'd have it on the back of the
truck and they would drive it up there
or they'd [__] put a bedliner in a
Chevy Silverado and have no bedliner in
the Ford they take like the [__]
suspension out or something they just
drop all these bricks in there and be
like see this what happens if you drive
a [__] Ford it's like I think that
would happen any truck if it didn't have
a bedliner I think you would [__] it up
um so anyways I'm [__] babbling here
uh but this week I have
um what do I got I got uh northfalk
Virginia on Tuesday tomorrow I have uh
Atlanta
Georgia on Wednesday on Thursday I have
Hollywood W
Florida and then Friday I fly in and I
got Madison Square Garden and then I am
done I am [__]
done
um and I have a bit that I'm going to do
at Madison Square Garden that I'm going
to tell you guys about afterward I hope
it goes well it's [__] on New
Yorkers so I'm kind of excited to do it
um I was speaking of [__] on stuff
there's some account on [__]
Instagram that has just been doing this
thing trying to get people upset that
they're going to have a Formula 1 race
in Las
Vegas that they're going to have a
Formula 1 race in Las Vegas at night
going right down the strip with all
those casinos lit
up I can tell you right
now whoever's directing that thing if
they shoot it right it's going to be the
sickest looking
race you know there's some really good
ones there's the one in Mexico where
they drive through an old
um an old baseball stadium
that's a cool one the one but the ones
at night the one like the one in
Singapore are amazing so there's some
woman there just going like uh they're
just destroying it it's a it's an
absolute failure and she's sitting there
going like uh you know usually this is
what the Venetian looks like and I guess
they drain the water out of those front
pools so they could put grandstands
there she said and now look at it
they've drained the the the uh the water
out of the
iconic Gondola rides at the V Venetian
it's like
iconic what the [__] that's not iconic
you know you go to Venice Italy that's
iconic not those two stupid pools at the
front of the Venice where they make it
seem like when you get on the ride they
take you through the whole [__]
Casino they don't those are two separate
rides they got two Kitty pools out in
front of the thing and they bring you
around it's like all a 3 minutes the
[__] ride and she's acting like
they're just going to leave these Grand
stands up and they're never going to
[__] put them back then she's showing
these palm trees going like they've
taken the
trees out of the side of the road it's
like yeah they don't want drivers
hitting trees and dying and she's like
going like how long's it going to take
to grow those things back it's like
they're not going to they're going to
buy full-size ones and stick them in
there and I guarantee you F1 is paying
for
it you can't get to The Fountains at the
Bellagio you know the bridges that go
over the thing they've put these this
paper up so you can't watch the race for
free it's like yeah yeah that's what
they do it's an event you're not going
to get to do it for
free and it's going to come in there
it's going to be an incredible success
and they're going to do it year after
year I think I don't know you think
they're going to rip the trees out year
after year I have [__] no idea but I
know they're going to put the trees
back I don't think the gondola the
iconic Gondola rides are over um I don't
know just making a big [__]
deal it's like I get it you don't like
the race you live out
there [__]
iconic I'll tell you right now if you
don't have the money to travel the world
like most people just go to Las Vegas
you can knock out like 10 of the biggest
[__] tourist attractions ever you get
to see the skyline in New York City you
get to see the pyramid you don't get to
see the pyramids you know that's some
aristocratic [__] you got to go to Egypt
for that but you can see the
pyramid all right if you like the
castles you
know of the French Countryside you can
go to the The
Aladdin you can see the Eiffel Tower
over at [__] the Paris you can take
Gondola rid oh another thing she was
talking about was the stupid [__]
volcano out in front of Treasure Island
that's like 25 years old that was
[__] stupid the day they put it in
it's just stupid it's not a
volcano they've shut down the
volcano it's 25 years old no one care if
you can't go to
Seattle you know you can just go to that
the the [__] space needle thing that
they got at the uh not the Stardust what
the hell do they call it the
stratosphere it's fantastic you can
knock out most of
Europe you can say you kind you you went
to Africa adjacent when you go to the
luxer right it's fantastic you can do
you can just do the whole goddamn thing
in a
day see some [__] walking down the
street I mean it's it's a great great
town to go to why can't they have a
[__] car race there you miserable
[__]
um Jesus you guys watching the NFL
football
yesterday the [__] Baltimore Ravens
beat the [__] out of the Seattle
Seahawks I had the
Seahawks the Las Vegas Raiders beat the
[__] out of the Giants I had the Giants
those [__] games were over before
they even started how about the Raiders
man
they fired their Coach Josh McDaniel
right I'm psyched I hope he comes back
to the Patriots because the way we
[__] played
yesterday it's I be honest with you for
the first time this season I'm actually
really concerned like just watching the
bonehead plays that we were doing we
[__] stop a drive we intercept the
ball in the end zone the guy runs like
22 yards east west and then takes I'm
yelling you know get on a knee down it
down it get on the ground runs like
[__] 25 yards east East West takes it
out of the end zone gets tackled on the
nine or the 10 yd line it's like what
the [__] are you
doing taking stupid penalties on special
teams we're down by three we stop them
three and out or whatever we kill a
drive they go to punt the
ball somebody lined up in the neutral
zone and we got a holding call holding
call
declined ah Jesus Christ and then they
take the [__] offsides penalty which
gives them five yards and a first down
and they get to chew up the clock even
more we just kept doing [__] we just
kept doing [__] like that so um I don't
know it is really really hard to
watch
um a bunch of people playing that level
of disrespectful football for [__]
bill bellich because there's no [__]
way you know any team I've ever seen
that he has coached has ever made that
many of them that that amount of [__]
stupid
mistakes and what's funny is the locals
are blaming him like did the game pass
him by it's like dude are you guys out
of here [__] I can't I'm I don't even
I don't even want to see
that just watching these idiots talking
about that [__] that's like uh that's
like the New York Knicks when they threw
Charles Oakley out of the [__]
Garden certain things you don't do but
anyway how about the [__]
Raiders I don't know who that new coach
is but I already believe in that guy and
the Raiders were always so [__]
confusing to me I was like they they
have an unbelievable amount of Talent on
that team and um you know I'm still
going to watch my Pats I [__] love
the Pats I don't give a [__] good or bad
I'm still always going to watch him but
um the late game I'm going to I'm going
to be watching the Raiders man
you know they got the redheaded Ginger
coming in there on [__]
defense giving us a good
name Max whatever the [__] his name is
um Christ am I catching another goddamn
cold this isn't even is this even
possible oh by the way do you know what
the [__] I did I did the
uh I did that raw ginger [__] I told you
guys that with the honey and the lemon
you know it didn't stop me from getting
a cold but I'll tell you it neutralized
it kept it from going down in my throat
Bill we don't give a [__] dude oh you
know what I else I didn't do I didn't
[__] say congratulations to the Texas
Rangers I don't know if I did that yet
that was so great to see you guys
finally win a [__] World
Series you know oh look who it is
everybody old
zip
recruiter um you know it takes a team
everybody it takes a team to make this
show
successful no it doesn't it takes me and
Andrew thus just like it takes a solid
team to make any business successful so
if you're hiring how do you find the
best people for your team OH
ZIP uh and right now you can try it for
free for at ziprecruiter.com here's why
you'll be grateful you tried zip
recruiter for your hiring matching
technology uh matching technology
zip uh uses smart technology to scan
thousands of resumés to find the most
qualified people for your job see why so
many business
owners uh and hiring managers are
thankful for a zip
recruiter I'd be grateful if you could
go to this exclusive website I'd be
grateful I'd have my hat in hand if
you'd go to this web address right now
to try out zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com again that's
ziprecruiter.com oh look at they cut
down the [__] copy finally my
favorite line ever zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire okay and we're
back and we are back oh this is one of
my I just glanced at this
one if this isn't like a a a sign of the
time of how busy people are how much
they're working and how many different
things they're doing it doing on on you
know at the same time this person said
talk faster no one has ever told me to
talk
faster I I've had a lot of what can you
repeat that you mumbling [__] um talk
faster suck it you white pasty
[__] uh now that that's out of the way
love the C podcast Bill been listening
since 2011 I usually run it at 2x speed
because you actually sound like yourself
20 years
ago um yeah well as you get older your
voice gets [__] deeper that's kind of
you know that's why singers can't hit
the [__] high notes and [__] all
right uh listening to you at normal
speed now is like strategic Grill
locations versus Mitch all
together
um oh those Mitch Hedberg I have no idea
what that is okay anyways keep up the
good work and stay out of Indianapolis
for [__] sakes be are some [__]
from New Jersey well dude that has to do
with you all right two times faster
you're telling me I'm talking twice is
[__]
slow um or you like the way that I
sounded back then all right maybe I'll
play some of my Robert Plant records a
little
faster
um talk faster you don't want me to talk
faster you want me to talk at a higher
pitch voice I believe like Michael
Jackson maybe somebody you know every
stupid [__] week I look at the thing
and I and I end up hitting stop so I got
to send two of these things rather than
one I don't even know what I just did
here anyways Reno
show Dear Mr BM bird I was there last
night at the Reno show well that was
last week okay I had a blast was so much
fun to laugh that much was great to see
you in person a nice fat tip help me
avoid that Dreadful line in the cold
yeah I do not understand what the [__]
was going on with the line outside the
Reno show it's like the show was at 8:
and it was like they didn't open the
doors until
8 um and I like how this person is not
going to tell anybody what the tip was
he said and I am a longtime lady list
listener and big fan got to tell you
what I enjoyed most the sign language
interpreter who was off to the left for
a deaf couple uh I sat right behind them
to see her interpret your foul mouth was
absolutely
hysterical I love how she signed the
story about your son talking about balls
which grew into a larger ball bit uh
then on the massage story she was on
fire with her hands making all kinds of
lewd motions it was the best I wish I
saw that question is she part of your
crew if not you should consider bringing
her along when that service is needed
love you hurry back um no I had no idea
and I'm glad wherever they put her cuz I
find people signing unbelievably
distracting cuz they always like stick
them up on the stage so now you're on
stage with this other [__] person you
know I don't know there has to be a
[__] way to do it
um because I just get like add and I'm
just looking at the person and I just
want to be like are you deaf too can you
talk where'd you get that sport coat and
then it just kind of makes me actually
have a worse show all right so if you're
deaf if you could just stay home for me
for me you know um kidding of course
before somebody gets like Bill Burr says
[__] you to deaf people all right
avocado
trade oh boy here we we go dear Billy
guacamole breath
Burr I'd love some [__] guacamole
right now that'd be a great way to start
the goddamn day huh some guac and some
chips um anyway during your rant on
Monday's podcast you mention your
dissatisfaction with paying for extras
like fries like fries or
guacamole um okay I don't like the way
you phrase that paying for extras what I
was saying is why is that
extra I understand that guacamole would
be extra on the East Coast but when I
live in California and I have an avocado
tree in my front yard it's not exactly a
rare thing why am I paying extra french
fries always came with a sandwich and
all of a sudden I go to Reno and they
ask me if I wanted to upgrade from
potato chips to french fries and all of
a sudden trying to like make me feel
like they're trying to
like like the way they've pulled off
this scam with with guacamole is [__]
or or avocado is
extra you know what they want to do now
they want to have everything is if we
can get every this how these corporate
[__] think if everything could have
avocado
status and we could just [__] talk to
people like potatoes of these rare
[__] things and that french fries are
are like this this high level of [__]
Cuisine it isn't it's blue [__] food
it's plate filler horseshit okay it's
one level above klaw I'd say it's a
little higher than that although you
know something people's klaw game is
fantastic when I was growing up like you
didn't even eat klaw it was literally
they had like wallpaper paste it was all
milky and just disgusting and you had to
put a napkin down next to it because the
they they used to make it so [__]
runny and then finally the Food Network
came along back when they used to teach
you how to cook rather than sitting
there competing with each
other you know you got you know here's a
couple of pork chops make pancakes how
am I going to do that figure it out you
got 10 minutes it's such that channel
the Food Network is absolute [__]
garbage it's [__] garbage they used
to teach you how to cook and you would
watch these [__] great chefs cook it
was fantastic molto Mario say what you
want about what he did at the Afterparty
during the [__] day molto Mario
watching that guy cook was was [__]
amazing
was [__] amazing so anyway um that's
what I'm talking about here my
dissatisfaction with paying for extras
they're not
extras they're not
extras they've just for some reason all
of a sudden been labeled like they're
these special things he said you
correctly
asserted this guy's getting all legal
that most avocados we consume are from
Mexico 80% come from the Mexican state
I'm going to [__] this
up it's m i c h o a c a
n yeah I mean closest thing I can say to
that is Manny Machado I know I'm going
to [__] it up and I know it's got some
badass [__] way of saying it I I
don't I don't want to [__] that up uh
there is an unsavory reason prices
consistently are going up the cartels
increasingly are controlling the avocado
trade well look at them gradually
becoming a legit
business yeah why the [__] are we
involved in this cocaine and all of this
stuff having to go around killing people
let's get in this avocado [__] we don't
have to [__] hide in the woods they
say this shouldn't be surpr be s a
surprise considering that Mexico exports
2.8 billion in avocados to us each year
of course the cartels want it in what
I'm worried about now is the price of
limes
which have gone up a lot recently much
in part because the cartels are getting
into that business it's a sad State of
Affairs to know that our grocery store
purchases now come at the cost of
innocent Mexican farmer Farmers lives
well where did farmers get killed in
that
um but I'll tell you this dude you're
you're you're still kind of
like letting corporations off the hook
because whatever
American corporations don't give a [__]
about the cartels down there okay if
California could give them an avocado
cheaper they would just go over there so
I'm sure to keep the price
down that the the Mexican farmer the
legit honest dude isn't is barely
getting paid anything and the cartels
make sure that you know they're able to
make their money and the corporations
are able to [__] you know they stay
under the price of California avocados
it's so [__] filthy
man sorry for the downer all the best to
you and your family and go [__] yourself
yeah man
um that was a downer cuz that really I I
just like watching what's going on in
all the people suffering over there in
Israel and Palestine it's just [__]
brutal and it just blows my it just
blows my mind that war is still
legal you know what I mean it just blows
my [__] mind that people can kill
kids in husbands and wives and just
regular [__] people like the [__]
that that that like goes on around the
world us included it's just blows my
[__] mind and then meanwhile there's
all of this this [__] virtue
signaling about you know not making fun
of fat people and all of that [__] but
all of that [__] all of that
stuff can't do any of that make sure you
say they and all of this stuff and you
know we're making the world World better
it's like we still go to war we still
shoot [__] missiles at people and
people go in and they blow up [__]
people just going to a festival and
stuff it's just it's
unbelievable well you know there's
probably a whole bunch of money behind
that too right all right this is getting
depressing how the [__] do you bring up
guacamole and then just end up going
down that rabbit hole I'm sorry all
right hockey
accident hi Bill the first
responder
oh [__] did you hear about the death of
Nottingham Panthers forward
Adam uh
Johnson I
didn't um he was killed in a freak
accident during a game in England
recently when his throat was cut by a
skap yeah man that that every once in a
while I a kid I went to high school with
he caught a skate right to the neck and
he was bleeding profusely and it just
missed his jugular he could have died
too um the English Ice Hockey
association association are introducing
neck guards as mandatory starting next
year um I know there there have been
accidents in the US but you guys don't
use NE neck guards do you thanks and go
[__] thank you thank you for your
service and go [__] yourself and thanks
for all your work um the
you guys like somebody has to die or
almost die and then um we go oh we got
to stop doing that like you know the
Nets that they have to protect the crowd
from deflected pucks like they didn't
put those things up even though they
were already up in Europe they didn't
put those up until that poor girl died
in uh Columbus Ohio one of the worst
[__] things I saw in goalies didn't
wear neck
guards I want to say Tom baraso I forget
who it was
he [__] you know it was bunch of guys
came down crashing the net and somebody
lost their lost an edge and came in with
one skate high and caught him right in
the neck and I'm doing dude I'm telling
you it was like a [__] sprinkler he
put his hand up to his neck and the [__]
was like the blood was coming out
between his fingers like everybody
thought thought he was going to die like
he was like you know like a centimeter
away from just bleeding out right on the
[__] ice so then they were like all
right
um I don't know I think that that might
be a players
union thing like they'll and I think a
lot of players be like well you know
what are the odds it's going to affect
my performance the comfort you know of
it or whatever well I'm sorry to hear
that I wonder what happened he obviously
was down on the ice he fell down and
somebody else came
in oh my God that's [__] terrifying
um oh speaking of which I got to talk to
Ken lindman about the brawl in the hall
Chris Nyon cuz Chris Nyland pushed him
when he went down the hall and then uh
lindman chased him down there and then
that's when the fight happened and then
that's when the benches faced each other
and then the Canadians came off and I
was at that [__] game look it up look
it up on YouTube the Boston Bruins the
brawl in the hall all right odd question
here's an odd question for
you right this might this might get a
little
odd um what do we got here I was
watching uh I can't say the movie not
allowed to promote it uh last night and
was shocked to see Mr Burr wearing a
Newark Wayne co-pilots t-shirt the
Newark co-pilots played in Newark
smalltown east of Rochester New York
from 1968 to 1979 Hall of Famer Robin ya
one of my favorite players of all time
and one of my favorite teams the
Milwaukee BL Brewers I love them back
then Ben olvy Robin
ya
um who the hell was I was get the Kansas
City Royals and
Brewers storman Gorman Thomas was he on
the
Brewers and vukovich was on
uh Kansas City I can't remember anyway
um Paul M uh Hall of Famer Robin y was a
17-year-old rookie for the co-pilots in
um and got called up to the Brewers in
1974 that's right at 18 the co-pilots
played in the New York Pen League I know
Mr Burr's character had co-founded a
vintage sportswar company so I can
understand him wearing something vintage
it just seems that like the co-pilots
were such a deep dive that I was
wondering if there was a conscious
decision to have him wear that shirt or
was it just a uh a random pick by the
costume designer was anyone on the crew
a Brewers or co-pilots fan as long as a
lifelong resident of Newark it was
something cool to see
um yeah well we were supposed to have
like a Mitchell andess type of a company
and we couldn't get we didn't have the
money to get licensing from uh from
major um you know the major sports
league so I'm trying to remember
basically what happened was we found a
company that made all of that stuff and
they had old like uh Negro League
baseball uniforms and um isn't that
weird saying that like you're not
supposed to say that word anymore but
you can say it if you say League after
it it's kind of
weird so and then they had like all
these uh yeah just basically these
defunct um Semi-Pro sports leagues and a
lot of them look cool and it just looked
cool hanging from the rafter
so that was how we ended up with that
and all those other jerseys and the
reason why I picked the newer co-pilots
is because I have a pilot's license and
I like I like that and then I also
um you know what a lot of people don't
know is that the uh the Seattle
Pilots
um you know there was the Seattle Pilots
before the Brewers so there was the
co-pilots that must have been their
minor league team wow just sort of
figuring that out I don't know if that's
true so the co-pilots were their minor
league team and the pilots for like a
year there was a team in Seattle called
the Seattle Pilots they ended up moving
to two milwauke and were called the uh
they became the
Brewers and now you know the rest to the
story
man
um I saw some guy that was trying to
claim that the [__] Yankees came out
of a uh basically a
slur for uh people from
Denmark and he delivered it with such
confidence that I and I watched I went
like I think that's [__] I don't
know why there was something about it I
just didn't believe it but I also didn't
do any research so he was claiming
that you
know up in New England it was M mainly
people from like Great Britain English
people and then down in New York you
know man the Manhattan area initially
was was uh settled by people from
Denmark so of course even though both
groups of people are white they still
can't even get along right they have to
come up with some sort of [__] slur
for [__] people from Denmark so what
did they do they just took like the two
uh the the two [__] most common names
it's like you know they call Irish mix
because of you know McDonald and all of
that type of [__] right so they
basically did that to them and one of
them was like yans and something else
was whatever and from the yans came like
yon Yankees or something like that I
don't know I don't believe it there's a
bunch of different like and then Yankees
then they did then when we started to
break away from them Yankees just became
the name for like a country bumpkin that
thought he was [__] cultur was but
was too stupid to realize that he wasn't
human beings are just [__] awful you
know and all of this [__] that they did
back then you now see it with like you
know typical entitled Tesla driver and I
sit there walking around look at this
[__] guy I bet he drives a G wagon
and takes [__] ice
baths [__] jerk off right you know um
why is
that you know why doesn't God do a
better job making
people when is he going to get it right
you know occasionally you'll [__]
meet somebody that's actually a decent
human being but it it really is just so
[__]
rare um and I'm definitely uh part of
the problem I was doing the second show
last night at Foxwoods and I was just on
stage just saying all of this [__] and I
just started thinking like what the [__]
happened to me you know I don't think
there's one ounce of of of I just sound
like a [__] up here I was really going
in this [__] nice this nicer
Direction with my comedy and now I was
up there you know what it just stemmed
from the fact that that that the the
just that feeling of [__]
hopelessness that that corporations are
just completely out of control
corporations and Banks and corporate
news and they're just they're just
keeping us all at each other's [__]
throats and every week they come up with
a new scam where something that that
came with something is now extra or it's
more [__]
money and then these [__] politicians
meanwhile are voting that they can't get
[__] tried for insider
trading I know I keep talking about just
blows my mind and everybody knows that
and they just [__] roll their eyes
and that's it and then meanwhile the New
Yorker not the New York Times did an
investigative report on a stand-up
comedian's act so they couldn't get the
Daily Show it's like that's where you
that's where you're putting your [__]
efforts all right
whatever so anyways the Boston Bruins
finally had their first loss the other
night I think it was to the Red Wings
but we're I think we're 91 in one uh and
I'm really excited about that because uh
a buddy of mine who knows a bunch about
hockey was trying to tell me you know I
was like hey you know they signed van
reik for a year whatever you know I
don't think we're going to be that bad
we got this kid coming up whatever his
name is he's been scoring some goals he
goes no don't be fooled he goes this is
a rebuild year but just to get people to
buy tickets they're going to act like
they're really [__] trying here and
uh then we went out through the west
coast and we [__] smoked everybody
out there and he goes all right but you
know you know only one of them you're
going to see in the playoffs and now
finally this dude had to admit like all
right man you know they're better than I
thought so uh very excited about that
but I will tell you in Boston the big
excitement is the Boston
Celtics and I've had a number of NBA
people going I'm telling you right now
they're going to win the NBA
championship just [__] telling you
right now that that's going to happen I
mean obviously I hope that that happens
but it's a long long ass [__] season
and
um I don't know [__]
about NBA
basketball but I know they they just a
couple of guys out there that like I
don't give a [__] if like the Miami Heat
last year you know like what they were
ranked versus the way that they played
they were just killing everybody like I
don't know the regular season is just
the regular season all right and I will
tell you this the Boston Bruins have
absolutely crushed the regular season
since last season and right up until now
our record is just AB it's
ridiculous and we end up losing in the
first
round to the
Panthers so
um yeah what is it mean I don't know
what but it's at least you know at least
we're not [__] Nick fans those poor
bastards every goddamn year it's so
[__] up it's so [__] up that the
Knicks have gone this long without
winning a championship like it's like
the amount of unbelievable
players that have come out of New York
City Hall of Fame [__]
players I think Dr J was from here New
York City Kareem Abdul Jabar when he was
luel cinder
um I don't know ailan [__]
guys have come here and they just can't
and in like like they got at least back
in the day I don't know what it is they
used to talk about they would have guys
playing on courts out in Brooklyn or Up
In Harlem that could actually you know
play against NBA players it was just
some guy in a
park you know just out of the respect
for the talent pool of people like it
just doesn't make any [__]
sense that they've been this bad for
this [__]
long you know I'll tell you what else
doesn't make sense it's the fact that
the the the the Nets moved from New
Jersey to Brooklyn and all those Nick
fans became net fans it's really bizarre
to me um like how you could have abandon
the Knicks I mean as much as they
haven't won championships I mean that's
a [__] legendary franchise it's a
great
name
um and they play in Madison Square
Garden why the [__] would you want to go
out to the barlay center in Brooklyn
where you could go to [__] Madison
Square
Garden I don't know anyway what are you
going to do
um so uh I went one and three again
after going two and two every single
week and then
going uh 3 and one one week I've now
gone and I was two games above 500 I am
I've gone one and three I think three
[__] weeks in a row I am now four
games under 500 if you're paying
attention on the anything better podcast
all right I'm going through a [__]
slump here it happens with everybody I
got a [__] can turn it around hopefully
it'll happen this week all right all
right so that's the podcast everybody
once again thank you so much for
everybody who came out to my shows at
Foxwoods thank you to anybody that's
going to my shows this week thank you to
everybody that came out this year once
again I get to live my dream as a
standup comedian it's a ridiculous priv
privilege and uh I wouldn't be able to
do it if you guys didn't show up you
guys make my life awesome all right
that's it go [__] yourselves and I will
check in on you on
Thursday